if I'm looking for a man if a man tells
me he doesn't like Andrew Tate I'm like
okay goodbye right right right imagine
as a guy wouldn't you like Andrew Tate
right right exactly unless you're Logan
Paul with an agenda right exactly in
which case red [ __ ] Flag right so
when a man's like I don't like Andrew
Tate I'm like okay next okay
um but Sarah let's go back to you you
said after you before you watched a lot
of his content you didn't like what he
had to say and there's some sort of
things that you probably still don't
like as far as like The Grooming of the
girls what is it like if you can
pinpoint what women are like ugh I hate
you buddy Adam whoever because you like
Andrew Tate can you pinpoint what
precisely
triggers women
maybe the age thing maybe the fact that
he just puts them all I mean like when
you're at like 18 to 20 you're stupid
you you don't know nothing yes so that's
how they like them I know I know that he
he's not true
I saw a video of him straight up saying
you gotta fight and during those ages so
you can groom them like so you can find
in other words you can find their yeah
sorry I don't mean to cut you off can I
just add to that I think it's really
interesting because I really understand
like I do understand why men want women
at such a young age that they can mold
them like I fully fully get it because
you know you want her on your path
before she becomes indoctrinated by
feminism and you know she's all about
the career and doesn't want to you know
support you
um and everything like that I can't
remember I was going with this actually
doesn't affect everyone though like you
can have a mind of your own and do your
own thing like you don't have to you
don't have to like go one way or the
other like I think you can be smart and
successful and beautiful I mean we've
come a long way both box and Juvederm
like today is 30 and 48 like yesteryears
you know I'm saying people live longer
now like you don't have to find them in
that time period like everything else he
says I swear is like intelligent and
then when just that it just seems
outdated oh I was sorry yes what I was
going to say was it's fascinating
because because I get why men want them
young so they're motable right but when
I think of myself even like two or three
years ago I mean when I was like even
when I was like 20 21 22 I don't even
think I would have been a good wife like
you couldn't even mold me at that age
like I I'm very Christian my brother and
a lot of my opinions are because he
molded me right but even so you just
couldn't make me a good housewife at 20
21 or 22 or 23. it wasn't until even 24
it was until I was like 25 I was like um
actually even in the last six months
like I would be a great wife now but
like I'd be away I'd be a much better
wife today than I would be six months
ago
so it's like yes I understand mold her
when she's young but even so even when I
was like 20 I just wouldn't be a good
housewife I think that just comes down
to how you're being raised right because
if you grow up in a two-parent
well-rounded and I'll say religious
household you're going to be absolutely
fine being a housewife and a
stay-at-home mom 20 to 24. but I think
that just shows where women are at and I
don't think you can get away from
feminism every woman is a feminist to a
little bit of a degree I talk to average
women pretty frequently and I can
understand why men want to go younger I
don't think they want us dumb I think
they want us to be cooperative and not
combative and I've worked with women
sometimes I coach women and I really
hate and don't okay hate is a strong
word I really dislike coaching women
that are 30 and older because it's too
hard to break the mental models that
they've already formed and how old was
the woman that you were talking to in
Miami do you think
um [ __ ] uh late 20s I think she was 29
right late 20s so that's like an example
of really bad girl game and
indoctrination you do something nice for
me I tell you you like this guy and
basically in my mind I think that you're
a scumbag but these same women are going
to complain that they're not dateable
and that they're single in their 30s
whereas like for me I don't feel bad for
you like you had a choice you could have
been a wife sooner I mean what whatever
um but my point is is that that's a lot
of American women right now they're just
outright disrespectful ungrateful
unattempt and it's I think it's a
struggle on both of the Sexes right now
Nat you want to weigh in
[Music]
um
uh sorry I was looking at the chat
um we'll get to the super chat in a sec
say that again we were talking about
Andrew Tate yes and uh Leia and we were
I started the conversation with Sarah
basically saying if you could pinpoint
what women don't like about Tate then we
kind of got into the feminism component
and um you just looked like you were
ready to talk and I maybe I
misinterpreted that it's okay you know
I'm ready to talk
if you could pinpoint what people don't
like about it exactly what women get
triggered about it she said the age and
the moldable by the way I'm gonna weigh
in on this moldable young age in a
second I think it's really just like
tone like like can I just be honest like
sometimes like it can the clips that I
saw him were very aggressive very angry
and like women take that as like being
like sculpted at you're like you know
being like yelled at and I think if he
was able to deliver a message in more of
a relatable way for women but I don't
think that's what he's like his goal
it's not for women it's for the men out
there yes
um so I think just like his tone I think
if he like if people if you listen to
his content as a woman that's not ready
to be offended you can really get you a
right man that you want that's correct
like if you like ladies they're you guys
are not being very smart with this
that's what I'm saying I think it's I
think it's really the tone like if he
can just adjust his his way of speaking
so that he's able to not only gravitate
towards the man but also get the ladies
to understand a perspective
um ladies will really I think
develop and change in a different way
now of course like age and everything
nobody wants to hear they're getting
older and as you get older you can't
have X Y and Z but it's a reality so
it's like you're better off to like
consider the factors and then move
accordingly
um so I really just think it's the way
his message is being delivered now of
course I don't agree with everything
this guy says but majority of the things
it's pretty valid factual points so I
really just think it's the way his
message is being delivered got it um
number one he's not changing his tone
nor should he got him this far do you
play so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
foreign
[Music]